Ray's gone home this is the second
person in just a few weeks that's
dropped out Jewett dueting injuries what
is going on in the ballroom you know
dancing is a very physical and hard
sport if you don't take care of your
body even if you're a pro football
player who is in the Hall of Fame you
know you can get injured so I'm really
proud now that Hannah every morning
takes 45 minutes to warm up while you're
warming up you're listening to Taylor
Swift who happened to post your dance
from last week dreams come true for
Swifties everyone that was so incredible
I was so excited I freaked out he texted
and was like Taylor so I'm just wasted
our video it was on her birthday too
there's a great birthday present
the audience was celebrity-packed and I
know that your new friend Demi Lovato is
here to support you we saw in the
audience you guys connected at the
Bachelorette right mental um we she
started watching the show and her mom is
a big fan and so her mom got her into it
and so we kind of connected before then
and she has just been such a great
support for me and I'm just really glad
that she was able to go you know show
business she's been in show business for
a long time so you've been thrown into
this but has she given you advice to
deal with the headlines and the prize
she's so great like even I had a harder
week this week and she was like hey if
you need to come over and just hang out
and watch it maybe like that's what I
need right now I don't I'm really
appreciative of somebody that just
supports me and loves me for me and I'm
glad that we had that relationship
and you paid it back a little bit
because rumors are you set her up with
Mike and then he went on the record
saying she was a great kisser he is sir
Tana I mean I like Mike and I love Danny
as well so whatever is happening with
them that's their business not mine that
is an excellent celebrity friend answer
that's how you answer these questions
and you showed up the bachelorette party
without a spray tan you know what I
forgot that I was actually gonna be
stripping that week and I did copping I
did copping on my back so I was really
good he didn't see my back about all the
celebrities other than Demi we had Demi
we had Zooey Deschanel we had the
property brothers we had Bobby from
queer I we had Nick file we had crystals
Demi Demi not Demi no God don't forget
her nerve-racking should be looking
around as you're dancing and see like
celeb slip slip slip slip so I've had to
learn from the very first week that if I
don't know where they're sitting from
before we start then I cannot look
around so I the first time I got really
distracted by all the glitz and the glam
and all the people and so I really just
try to Zone in with sweet start but then
also when I never they're there I'll
wave after I'm dead no for me
[Music]